all right this one's definitely a little
strange so buckle up we're going to talk
about weird kids videos and gaming the
algorithm if you don't have kids you
quite understandably probably don't
watch many YouTube videos intended for
kids and when I say kids really I mean
babies we're going to be talking about
the YouTube equivalent of Teletubbies
and Blue's Clues videos aimed at a
preschool audience I bring that up first
because as we go through all of this
it's helpful to keep in mind that the
target audience isn't really making
coherent viewing decisions preschool
audiences are largely passive viewers
watching whatever is put in front of
them rather than seeking media out
there's a lot of content on YouTube for
preschoolers that is more or less what
you would expect pretty much any popular
television show like Sesame Street and
Peppa Pig also has a substantial
presence on YouTube in fact a compelling
argument could be made that Peppa Pig is
more popular online than through
broadcast television
but as with any popular YouTube genre
there is an attendant flood of
low-quality imitators and bootleggers
much of it is exactly what you would
expect people uploading stuff they
couldn't find online or just re
uploading stuff to skim ad revenue then
there's the YouTube specific genres such
as surprise egg videos toy unboxings and
Nursery Rhymes things that are more or
less what you'd expect from the phrase
YouTube but for kids you know YouTube -
all the cussing but there's also a lot
that decidedly off
just something about it
[Music]
yeah so you may already be familiar with
this particular sub-genre of children's
media if you delve into it now in 2017
what you'll find is a hallucinatory mix
of popular characters being run through
a gristle mill of family finger songs
wheels on the bus monkeys on the bed
wrong heads Johnny Johnny yes papa
color and shape matching and skits
revolving around pregnancy poop and
adults randomly kicking the crap out of
kids a popular recent article by James
bridle titled something is wrong on the
Internet takes a fairly broad dive into
this subject focusing on the generally
unsettling nature of many of the videos
youtuber h3h3 has done a popular video
on people intentionally hijacking the
genre with adult content
Fredrik Newton have down the rabbit hole
has done a video on the history of the
family finger song in specific and let's
play channel retsu pray has done a
number of commentaries for animated
videos with titles like Mickey and
Minnie Mouse baby's missing abducted
lethal injection Mickey Mouse Clubhouse
cartoons full the moral of the story
don't murder children I guess I mean
that's alright now the actual origins
here are muddled starting in India in
the late 90s with low-grade animated
rhyming video sold on cheap video CDs
the jump to YouTube starts around 2010
with the animation companies basically
just uploading their existing catalogue
but it doesn't really break into the
attention of the Anglosphere until 2013
2014 with the proliferation of family
finger song videos and channels
dedicated to posting minut variants of a
basic template with each year as new
styles of children's videos gained
popularity their format is simply folded
into the mix the wordless superhero
skits genre in particular is a fairly
new addition exploding almost out of
nowhere in mid 2016 with adults dressed
in popular character costumes almost
universally including spider-man and
Elsa acting out low-quality absurdist
skits the rapid proliferation is largely
comprehensible the material barriers to
entry are low requiring only a handful
of Halloween costumes some friends and
they
lack of dignity and the standards for
quality among four-year-olds are even
lower than average for YouTube as with
the family finger song and a dozen other
subgenres this too has metastasized
rapidly into a procedurally generated
animation hellscape a lot of the
disturbing elements can be attributed to
this culturally disconnected history
these are for the most part being
cranked out by South Asian animation
companies that for any of a variety of
reasons don't share the American Idiot
form of what acceptable children's
entertainment looks like or maybe they
simply don't care there's an odd
interplay of mimetics here where someone
will make something with the express
purpose of trolling people
unintentionally disturbing children's
animation for example that will gain
popularity and subsequently be absorbed
into the meme body of these channels
churning out content programmatically
Bridals article in particular spends a
good deal of time highlighting the
algorithmic structure of these videos
hundreds of channels uploading hundreds
of videos all operating off the same
recombinant ory logic of AI procedural
generation Bridal making a direct
comparison to automated on-demand Amazon
stores that place stock images on a
variety of products from coffee mugs to
cell phone covers these children's
videos form a sort of inverse Turing
test as whether they are made by
individuals who just don't care beyond
men maxing their search engine
optimization or are made by programs
smashing elements together from a word
cloud it is almost impossible to tell
the difference
even if made by humans they function as
though they were assembled by machines
for example this video titled
superheroes pregnant soccer balls fidget
spinner Spider Man Joker Hulk cartoon
funny kids video prank s-- is a series
of semi-coherent however surreal
segments including one where joker sells
Hulk and spider-man magical fidget
spinners pregnant Elsa and spider-man of
the supermarket and a bunch of
superheroes pouring M&Ms into a blender
now that last one is actually repeated
twice in the same video and the other
two segments can also be found in other
videos jokerz magic fidget spinners can
also be found in this video titled
spider-man Hulk pregnant frozen Elsa
colors gummy fidget spinner Joker prank
venom fun superheroes and pregnant Elsa
and spider-man at the supermarket is the
lead segment in the video frozen elsa
pregnant colors superhero spider-man
Hulk vs venom Joker fidget spinners
colors for kids the point is that the
videos themselves are procedurally
generated from a library of component
videos which are themselves generated
from stock assets motion capture
libraries and the handful of subjects
that four-year-olds find fascinating the
end result is as Mike Rugnetta put it
metadata slurry the animated videos are
hallucinatory recreations of the already
surreal originals down to unsettling
levels of specificity buried alive
outdoor playground finger family song
nursery rhymes animation education
learning video is clearly a Markov
derivative of the popular video buried
alive spider-man vs. frozen elsa baby
pink spidergirl joker family fun
superhero movie one of our previous
examples spider-man and pregnant elsa
the supermarket is an eerily specific
recreation of pregnant frozen elsa
giving birth and joker attack spider-man
Hulk superheroes movie compilation
[Music]
and yeah it's wild that the stuff made
by humans is still just word salad but
you need to keep in mind that the target
audience can't read so the title is
irrelevant beyond its function as search
engine optimization now there's already
something troublesome about the
fundamental structure of YouTube kids
young children particularly preschoolers
are prone to watching the same thing
over and over and over a kid may watch
any given video dozens or even hundreds
of times as a result many of these
videos have absurdly high view counts
with what would in other corners of
YouTube be suspiciously low number of
corresponding likes and comments this
again makes a bit more sense when you
consider that most four-year-olds can at
best only read a few words and can maybe
write their own name now that
troublesome structure built on a
foundation of chain viewing
four-year-olds gets all the worse when
you consider that it's a perfect
environment for mechanized exploitation
the standards for the content are
already so low that it is difficult to
distinguish what is the product of a
machine throwing elements together semi
randomly and what is the product of
adults who just don't care the behavior
patterns of kids chain watching videos
will not otherwise engaging is also
easily replicated by BOTS and while
there's no hard proof of any of these
channels botting it would be almost
effortless to hide if they were and
here's where it really goes off the
rails
so as I've already mentioned these
procedural animation videos crop up
across multiple channels the specific
pregnant elsa segment we've been using
as an example shows up in videos on
channels cartoon animation rhymes rhymes
lyrics cartoon rhymes animals for kids
rhymes for kids and who knows how many
others in case you're wondering if this
might just be a case of simple theft all
of these channels belong to the same
multi channel network named 3h uox 580
USR n6 h wh o kz jsq it's case sensitive
by the way i guess i'm saying that the
odds of them all ending up on that same
MCN are low you know there are 58
channels
- that MCN almost all of them posting
nearly identical content based off the
same source library everything about it
screams minimal human interaction the
strategy here is to cast a very wide net
with the illusion of diversity a single
channel uploading dozens of videos per
day will quickly trip YouTube spam
alarms but a network of dozens of
channels uploading one video each per
day won't YouTube's search algorithms
and recommended videos try to give you
content that's just like whatever you
just watched but they're also designed
to force a bit of variety to prevent a
single channel from totally dominating a
given genre the distributed spam
technique works around this meaning the
algorithm can deliver diverse results
from many different channels while
actually delivering results that all
point back to the same core entity but
that's not actually even the end of the
story you might notice that I've
stripped the audio entirely from all the
examples that I've used here and there's
a good reason for that so here's an
interesting experiment that I've already
done for you re upload a bunch of these
videos and watch the copyright claims
come rolling in I uploaded five videos
to a burner channel and within half an
hour had 32 copyright claims all of
which had the attached policy of a
global block one video in particular got
hit with 13 separate claims that video
was actually one that you might be
familiar with if you read James Bridals
article as he included it as an example
and that's buried alive outdoor
playground finger family song nursery
rhymes animation education learning
video now here's the breadcrumb trail
that video is taken from the channel
animals for kids one of the channels
that's part of the multi channel network
3 Huo X 580 us RN 6 HW h o kz jsq but
all of the copyright claims point to the
multi-channel networks mango Kids
wacked-out affiliate and mobile Walker's
- with the mango kids being the
overwhelming source of copyright claims
the important implication here is the
disconnect all of these videos contain
content that is rapidly claimed by three
separate networks each with a standard
worldwide block policy
but the content is demonstrably
available on channels under other
networks than the claiming network
meaning that the automated Content ID
claims are either being released or
modified it's not hard proof but it is
compelling and I feel it's fair to say
there is a good possibility that these
networks are in fact all the same root
entity mango Kids mobile Walker's
wacked-out and three Huo X are all the
same people
meaning that whichever one is in fact
the originating organization is
operating at least 400 separate YouTube
channels proliferating a spam of
children's content programmatically
dominating search results and
recommended videos now if you think that
YouTube is unaware of this I would point
out that the process of getting a
multi-channel network with the content
management privileges through YouTube is
not an automated process there is no
application form they are all handled
one at a time by YouTube's content
management teams these networks are
comprised entirely of channels that
exist purely to manipulate YouTube's
algorithms so why doesn't YouTube care
well because as long as advertisers are
unaware of how many of their impressions
are coming from four-year-olds sitting
with an iPad on autoplay then the trade
value of advertising on YouTube will
remain higher than the actual value and
YouTube will continue making money the
big reason why YouTube takes measures to
crack down on egregious examples of BOTS
watching videos is because advertisers
don't like the fact that they're paying
for ads shown to no one now that said if
we're honest and if we use the 1980s as
an indicator there's an awful lot of
advertisers who are ultimately ok with
their ads being bombarded on to toddlers
and plenty of creators willing to churn
out low effort content to facilitate
that and that's a downer ending
[Music]